[Music]
foreign
sure that was our shortest ever cold
open it just hit me the right way I'm
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's March 23rd 2023 we're live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
share subscribe tap that notification
Bell if you have not and I have to be
totally honest with you guys this is a
pre-tape it appears that I'm live to you
but actually right now I am on a plane
and route to Green Bay Wisconsin I've
got a gig at University of Wisconsin
tonight I'm going to try to get to
Lambeau Field this afternoon we will see
what happens uh and then we will not
have a show tomorrow and giving my guys
a three-day weekend while I am doing
some traveling but we wanted to do a
pre-tape for you today and I thought we
would do this with just sort of a recap
of like four or five things that I just
wanted to get to during the week that we
couldn't get to just sort of the general
Insanity recap and then and we will be
back at our normal schedule on Monday
before we do it let's talk about moink
box real quick uh I know you guys know
but some people don't know that 60
percent of U.S pork production comes
from one company owned by the Chinese
and their Hogs are given something
called ractopamine which is banned in
160 countries including China yet you
find it in your grocery aisle every day
there's a better way guys and I want to
tell you about moink that is Moo plus
oink moink delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door you choose the meat delivered in
every box like rib eyes to chicken
breasts to pork chops to salmon fillets
and much more plus you can cancel at any
time there is nothing better than
cooking their meats in my big green egg
on a Friday evening Shark Tank host
Kevin O'Leary called moink's bacon the
best bacon he's ever tasted and they
guarantee you'll say oink oink I'm so
happy I got moinked keep American
farming going by signing up at Mike dot
com slash Reuben right now and listeners
of this show get free filet mignon in
every order for a year that's one of the
best filet mignon you'll ever taste but
only for a limited time that's
m-o-i-n-k
box.com slash reubenmoinkbox.com Reuben
all right let's get to it General
Insanity recap uh we're gonna start with
a clip of Bill Maher but fear not Bill
if you're watching today I am not
criticizing you I actually think what
you were doing uh was pretty great you
had Andrew Yang on your show on Friday
night and people remember Andrew Yankee
ran as uh as a democrat in the last
election uh the sort of non-woke liberal
Elite really loved him I thought he was
a perfectly nice guy but it was clear to
me it really wasn't going to go anywhere
his big thing was Ubi your Universal
basic income basically meaning that the
government would give literally everyone
cash so that everyone would have a
Baseline to do what they wanted with
that money of course the inherent
problem with that is once you give
everyone a certain amount you're
deflating the value of money prices go
up okay fine this is economics 101.
anyway Yang went on uh real time on
Friday and Bill kind of handed it to him
it was sort of hilarious actually I mean
your big thing when you ran was Ubi yep
which is not a bowel problem it sounds
like it I always think about it I know
it's a branding thing
Universal basic income right which is
sort of what we did yeah during covet
okay so where are you now I mean I see
your I don't get your third party
because I read your website and it's a
bunch of mush
I'm not trying to be mean I'm just
saying it's not like specific it doesn't
even mention this and and why start a
third party which is a long shot anyway
if you're not going to be bold and so I
don't know exactly what bill was going
for there other than to just kind of
take him out but there's just something
sort of funny about it because the
non-woke Liberals and I would say that
Andrew Yang is a non-work liberal Bill
Mars and a non-work liberal they're sort
of on the same side and what they end up
doing as you guys know is they always
end up sort of saying the right things
but then getting people to vote the
wrong way meaning vote for Democrats so
I thought it was kind of nice there that
bill kind of just like smacked him
around a little bit like Ubi is just
sort of a soft step government giving
money meaning government taking money
and then giving money to people Everyone
Gets the same amount and then you can do
what you want with it all the reasons
that economically that doesn't work just
econ 101 for any of you that went to
college or just Google basic economic
theory but him smacking him around was
just sort of interesting because I just
don't think any of the sort of We're the
nice liberal thing works anymore so what
what Bill Maher is referring to there is
that Andrew Yang is running something
called the forward party we're not left
we're not right we're forward it's just
more sort of meaningless stuff and I
will say although I think Andrew Yang is
a perfectly fine guy he was once
interviewed by the New York Times you
guys know uh Mara gay she's come up on
this show every now and again She
interviewed Andrew Yang and asked him
why he did the white supremacist uh
Reuben report show she actually called
it the Dave Rubin show and yang didn't
really defend me so I have a little bit
of a a little bit of an ax to grind over
there anyway I just thought that was
kind of interesting but going from one
interesting Oddity of the media to
another actor Billy Porter I did not
know who this was until we did a little
check-in apparently he was on American
Horror Story a couple seasons of
American Horror Story he went on The
View and he sat down with the shrews of
the view and they went off on Ron
DeSantis in a completely insane way
enjoy
there's this
War trans people which is
an ldq Plus
Cabaret people it's a it's a circle of
life yeah you know why are they doing it
for power
yeah everything is about power and you
could always trace it back to the money
you say that all the time yeah you know
it's follow the money follow the power
power at any cost it's very hypocritical
you know the the leading cause of death
in children are guns yeah yeah they're
guns yeah
I know it's the morning and I'm not
supposed to be screaming but they're
guns yeah
not drag queen no leave us alone
you know and it's a distraction
it's a distraction on purpose we don't
know what to pay we don't know what to
pay attention to
all right so I don't know if he
considers himself or herself part of the
lgbtq plus Community or whatever with
the nail polish whatever sort of uh
irrelevant but just to be clear there is
no war on lgbtq people nobody's trying
to arrest them no one's trying to put
them in jail no one is saying that
consenting adults can't live as they
wish really no one in any version of
what happens in this country that is
anything remotely close to mainstream or
has anything to do with the legislative
process in any state no one's coming for
anybody no one's arresting trans people
here in Florida no one's arresting gay
people it's just crazy but there's a war
on trans people that's what he said and
she agreed there's a war on lgbtq does
it what what does I know Q means queer
but what does that mean that just means
you're like you're just like a little
bit like this you'll just kind of sleep
with anyone okay and then uh and then
there's a war on Cabaret
what these people are genuinely insane
The View
years from now they should put the view
in a time capsule and the aliens will
come down one day and they will open it
up and they will watch The View and
they'll be like we better get out of
here
nothing good is happening here uh okay
let's just do one or two more for you
before we get to the Reuben report dot
locals.com Community Q a we got a big
wide selection of questions for you
today uh if you did not see this the
moderna uh CEO was testifying uh for
congress for the Senate and uh Rand Paul
Senator Rand Paul from Kentucky
libertarian as you know on my short list
of same people in government uh he
basically destroyed the guy this is this
is just an absolute destruction and well
watch yourself
I also spoke with your president just
last week and he readily acknowledged in
private that yes there is an increased
risk of myocarditis the fact that you
can't say in public is quite disturbing
so the guy that Rand Paul is talking to
there is the CEO of modernist Stefan
bonsell we'll get to some video him in
just a second and basically Rand Paul is
like okay you're the CEO you're
testifying here I'm obviously not
getting the truth to you but off the
Record in a private conversation uh the
president of moderna he's actually
laying out the goods but if you want to
realize how deep these people are in on
it right they force these vaccines on
everybody they had all these government
organizations pressuring all of us to do
these things we now know the rates of
myocarditis we know all the vaccine
injuries
and even if none of that had had existed
even if this vaccine was perfect they
had no right to mandate it government
had no right to force companies to fire
people and all of that stuff that you
know all about but watch this here's
Rand Paul asking Stefan bonsell how many
times his kids have been vaccinated he
doesn't even know the answer
I'm not the clinician I would have to
discuss you have children I do have you
vaccinated your children I have how many
times
three or four times three or four times
I mean is that wild relative to
everything that has happened over these
last couple years you have the CEO of a
major pharmaceutical company really the
number two company besides Pfizer as far
as these mRNA vaccines these companies
have made hundreds of millions of
dollars if not billions of dollars and
have all sorts of contracts with all
sorts of governments they force this on
everybody he doesn't even know how many
times off the top of his head he
injected his kids with this stuff yet he
was forcing you to inject your kids with
it and I don't know how old his kids are
and it's largely irrelevant actually but
it's like if his kids come down with one
of those vaccine injuries and by the way
it may not be tomorrow but in seven
years if one of them has Bell's Palsy or
if one of them has myocarditis or one of
the other things or just an imbalance
literally balance is becoming an issue
for people or a vision problem or
whatever it might be it's like man you
will only have to look in the mirror and
I hope that the cash that you made on
the way was worth it and and uh as Brock
pointed out before as we were doing the
rundown it's like look they can do all
of these hearings and they do them often
right this is what government does
government investigates things but until
something happens to some of these
people until we get to the bottom of who
at the government was forcing Twitter to
censor people and then we fire those
people or someone is held to account to
some degree or someone
like this man are held to account and
lose their job or whatever it might be
think about a time we've lived in cancel
culture for however many years now five
years of cancel culture no one at modern
has been fired no one at uh at Pfizer
has been fired no one at well Twitter
got plenty of people have Twitter got
fired but that's only because Elon Musk
bought the freaking thing so we need
some of these things to be held to an
account otherwise we're basically just
doing The Show Must Go On more show more
show more show so actually in a few days
I'm going to DC for a couple days we're
going to meet about 100 of you guys from
locals and do a tour of the capital and
a bunch more I'm going to sit down with
Rand Paul and that's going to be one of
the things I'm going to ask him okay and
I've asked him this before by the way
but I'm gonna I'm gonna push him on it a
bit more which is okay we can keep doing
these hearings fauci can lie to you you
can talk to the you know CEO of moderna
and he can give you a whole bunch of
nonsense and but what is the point of
all of it what does it really get to
other than some things get exposed and
that's nice right it's nice to get a
little closer to the truth but what is
is the nuts and bolts
version of it on the other side what
actually happens or is there no other
side is it just about the show and then
life goes on anyway let's get to a
reubenreport.locals.com community q a
here we go uh Deborah says what are your
thoughts on the possibility that Silicon
Valley Bank was taken down intentionally
they love to create a crisis and then
Implement bad policy to save us from
ourselves
well I don't know about intentional
meaning did the bankers at Silicon
Valley intentionally give out all of
these crazy loans and these risky loans
with the hope that the bank would fail
knowing that they would get bailed out
because if anyone's going to pay the
price on this we know now it's not the
depositors it's not the companies that
we're putting money into the bank they
are getting bailed out but it is some of
the executives at the banks and things
like that so I don't know meaning that
they're going to get fired lose their
jobs it's going to harm their resume Etc
so I don't know that it was intentional
in that degree but I would say at the
macro level
it is quite possible that it's
intentional to a certain extent meaning
when you have a machine in place which
is what we have right now that says the
FDIC will insure you for 250 Grand
you've all seen that I haven't been to a
bank in a long time everyone does
everything digital now but I'm sure if
you go to most bank tellers still at
this point there's that little golden
black sticker right there on the window
on that glass window you're insured up
to 250 000 meaning if this Bank fails
for whatever reason
because of economic conditions because
of poor choices poor Investments too
many risky options Etc the government it
always says the full faith and credit of
the United States government which I
would say is wavering at best right now
uh they'll take care of it for the 250.
now these companies that went to Silicon
Valley Bank it focused mostly on
startups and startups especially Tech
startups are crazily risky as I've
explained many times and you guys know
this like anytime someone comes up with
an app or a tech company you're not
going to make money for a long long time
your goal is to get as many users on the
platform you want eyeballs on that
platform and then you figure out how to
monetize from there for those of you
that have been with us from the
beginning with locals that's how we
started it we made no money I put in
money on my own and then I tried to get
investors and we were running at a
deficit for a long time eventually we
found a way to partner up with Rumble
and now things have really expanded in a
really spectacular way I mean Stephen
Crowder who's basically the biggest live
streamer out there at this point maybe
number two to Rogan I mean he's you
using locals and Rumble Technologies
freaking awesome
um but most of these companies fail
these guys were more focused on
diversity equity and inclusion than they
were on risk management it turns out
they only had a risk manager for about
three months but that's like the number
one thing you would have at a bank
because the whole purpose of a bank is
we take money from you guys and we don't
just leave it in the bank we then invest
it in a various series of ways so that
we can make some money and you still
will always have access to your money
but they pissed that money away and on
top of all the economic conditions by
printing money that the the Biden
government did and inflation and
everything else it created a condition
that they were going to fail so to fully
answer your question I think there's
probably some level of a conspiracy here
but it's right in front of us and that
conspiracy is that the government always
gets bigger so remember 2008 these banks
are too big to fail bail them out and
then what did we do we made them even
bigger and now banks will just get
bigger and bigger and bigger and the
small guys eventually won't be able to
compete and that's kind of the way they
want us because they want us with less
choices whether it's economically or and
on the other way uh that we want to live
Grace says what does the average school
day look like for you and the rubinite
workers we see you for about an hour how
does it all work out working from home
until your side of the studio until your
side of the studio built uh will you and
the crew work there when it is built as
locals Rumble grows how hard it how hard
will it be to move the crew out of your
home now that you have the cute Junior
producers okay there's a lot there uh so
first off just on my day I'm an early
riser I'm up at about 6 30 or so I'm
kind of doing my thing with the kids
from about seven to about eight that's
usually when Phoenix and I are starting
to text back and forth figure out how
the show is going to look Phoenix
creates the the full rundown we kind of
make sure that the shape of it is right
and everything else and I'm playing with
the kids and doing some feedings maybe a
diaper change or two in the morning
something like that David gets up a
little bit later because he's with the
kids most of the day we try to take a
walk if we can so we got the double
stroller and the dog and we're out there
with the peacocks and the lizards and
everything else uh my whole crew uh
Connor and now Brock is here and Daphne
everybody arrives usually about 9 30 10
o'clock or so we do a rundown of the
show which is really just it's literally
like the stories that we've got the the
clips that I have to throw to but we
don't rehearse the show in any way
meaning anything that I'm doing on the
show just like now is just me telling
you what I think for better or worse but
we have a basic rundown uh and then
after the show you know usually
throughout the day I'll have like you
know a hit on Fox or a hit on Sky News
Australia I'm doing some stuff with them
now or some Newsmax stuff or another
podcast or whatever it is uh so Connor
is running uh everything on the
operation side of that and he's also in
here editing uh Phoenix is working on
other you know producing other segments
and we've got a bunch of travel now
Brock literally just got here this week
moved to the free state of Florida this
week so here he's here now handling
social media uh Daphne who's my
assistant and also managing a lot of
what goes on on the local side she's
helping us with house projects and now
with a bunch of baby things apparently
babies you gotta be wary of stairs and
pointy edges so we're working on some
things related to that and a fence
around the pool and a whole bunch more
uh and everyone kind of goes goes as
they please I always say to everybody I
don't mind if you do your work here home
Starbucks in the park on the beach I
don't as long as the work gets done I
don't care where anyone does it I am not
here to clock everybody and baby
everybody and I want everybody to enjoy
their lives which is why on this Friday
uh you know I'm just giving everybody
the day off it's like we've been busting
our butts I'm traveling it's okay let's
have a three-day weekend and it's
Connor's birthday so everyone will be
coming back here and I will be doing
something with moink meat on the uh the
Big Green Egg and that's it vinay says
if Larry Elder is the black face of
white supremacy is Dave the gay face of
homophobia
you know I just I hate this this lgbtq I
have nothing to do with these people I'm
gay with one dude that's it and I got a
couple other gay friends nobody's that
impressed with the whole thing nobody
cares nobody cares that's the thing live
your life but I probably am the gay gay
face of homophobia so
there you go uh James says how do we
counter the Democrats privilege as it
relates to the mainstream media
Democrats pull fast ones and the general
mainstream media reaction is just being
a politician Republicans pull fast ones
and there are statistics kept on the
number of Lies that they tell look we
cannot turn this thing around I I just
want to be clear about this I
always debate this with you guys right
this idea of how much attention do we
have to pay to these people because they
lie about things uh sorry I thought I
lost my bike there uh they lie about
things and they hide things and they
don't cover certain things and all of
the stuff that you guys know so how much
attention do we have to pay to them
because on one hand they're liars and
who wants to pay attention to them all
day like the view stuff on the other
hand a certain amount of people are
influenced by them I think for those of
you that are
red pilled awake whatever you want to
say it's just like we just have to
acknowledge it we just have to
acknowledge it there is no way that
MSNBC will ever give Ron DeSantis a fair
shake a fair Shake there is no way that
the New York Times will or CNN or Trump
or you know what I mean like you got it
and we have to once you acknowledge that
and then also realize that those guys
are dinosaurs you know we're we're
pulling huge numbers on our live streams
now where by the end of the day usually
our our YouTube live stream has
somewhere between 150 000 and 200 000
views and our Rumble live streams are
getting pretty close to that too around
150. so let's say around 350 or 400 000
people watch the full show that we're
doing here on a daily basis that is way
more than our watching MSNBC MSNBC shows
on this uh at this point on top of the
fact of all the clips that we put out
and everything else so we just got to
keep going on we just got to keep
building new things telling people the
truth and don't expect that the things
will turn around they're in too deep
they're not going to turn around and I
think once you realize that it starts
becoming empowering and it also makes it
so that you can make fun of them without
being angry all the time because
otherwise I'd be out of my freaking mind
right I'd be watching these clips and
I'd lose my freaking mind so there you
go uh Solana says how did you make out
at the dermatologist so as you guys know
about two weeks ago Justin with a
snaggly Freddy Krueger style nail I was
letting him you know he likes to kind of
grabbing my beard I let it I didn't let
him but he like got his finger in my
slashed the the eyelid on my left eye
and uh over the course of like a week
and a half it was getting like kind of
weird and itchy and scaly and I think it
got infected probably from a little
powder that we put on so I'm not too
shiny when we do the show especially
after I ate Shake Shack there can be a
little bit of shine to the skin from the
oil and uh I went to the dermatologist
yesterday they looked at it she actually
said it was it was quite an infection
she it's like whoa this is this is
really something uh 2.5 percent
hydrocortisone which I've used two or
three times and my eye
how does it look on camera right now
pretty good like it's we're getting
there we're getting there it's a little
dry and itchy still but but clearly that
stuff works you should not a little a
little medical advice which I don't give
often on the Reuben report let's not go
too crazy with the 2.5 percent that's
the prescription strength hydrocortisone
because it can thin out the skin and you
want skin on your eyeball so uh clip
that and send it on the Internet Bonnie
says after seeing the clip of fauci and
Bowser being humiliated by the guy in DC
it makes me question even more why
Republicans are not campaigning in these
neighborhoods it seems like the perfect
follow-up for Republicans to make their
case it should be they should be there
on the regular base on a regular basis
yeah they may take some pushback but
keep going back and making and make
conservative points why don't
Republicans try to win these votes
you are a hundred percent right and I
think that is going to start to change
you know Donald Trump made tremendous
inroads uh within the black community
okay uh it was double the amount of men
black men
voted for Trump the second time then the
first time
it's not a huge amount right it was
still only like seven percent uh but it
was but it was a doubling okay and if
you even double into a next election a
next election then you then things start
snowballing and really change
um the Republican message or let's say
the conservative message to the black
community or to the Latino Community or
if you don't even want to make this
about race if we just say let's just
talk about more impoverished
neighborhoods right because forget the
skin color of the people in that video
from a couple days ago if you just were
to go to an impoverished neighborhood in
the outskirts of DC and of course Bowser
is the mayor there and she doesn't seem
to care about these people what they
would want to really communicate to them
are the ideas of Thomas soul and Larry
Elder and the idea is that the
government has really sort of forced you
into this and then you could push some
ideas about personal responsibility
personal responsibility and some Jordan
Peterson type stuff right and that you
have a way of getting out of this but
it's going to be on you I think that is
a winning message you know yesterday we
showed you the the last clip of the show
was Jordan Peterson on Patrick bat
David's podcast talking about how the
conservative message of personal
responsibility really has value now it
there is a way to do this that's not
wagging your finger at those people
people but saying hey you got a chance
here's how you do it I think that's a
sellable message and it's way better
than the hysteria coming out of the
other side but you know deprogramming
people it takes time
Mitch says your Russell Brand interview
reminded me of the old Reuben report not
that there's anything wrong with the
content you're putting out now but would
love to hear more neutral heterodox and
anti-establishment voices on the show do
you think a more humanist libertarian
ideal could be the big tent idea that
could shift the populace towards a mass
Awakening well first off I I'm totally
fine hearing that you know I wish we
could find some more heterodox people
I'll tell you this we are going to DC
next week as I mentioned the other day
we every I think every Republican we
reached out to except for Mitch
McConnell said yes to us Mitch McConnell
they said no but he did offer to get us
in touch with some other people but
everyone else said yes we also reached
out to about a dozen Democrats we got no
responses we didn't even get no right we
got No No's we got zero responses so in
terms of heterodox thought now look
we're going to have some variants of
thought with those Republicans that I'm
going to have on and we're going to do a
few of them as panels just to mix it up
a little bit but I gladly would have sat
down with the Democrats look I know I
make fun of Democrats all the time and
some of them have probably heard me
making fun of them so they think I'm
going to be mean or something but I
don't think I'm known actually I was
criticized for it many times over the
years for being you know not the hardest
interviewer so you guys just know if I
sat down even if I sat down with AOC I
really would treat her with respect
within that I would I would challenge
her on some of the ideas but it would
not be done to just get you and destroy
you it really would not but we didn't
get one response as for sort of a more
uh humanist approach in some of these
libertarian ideas and how that could
lead to the wider tent you know I think
we're basically doing that you know one
thing that I'm very proud of is that
from what I can tell from communicating
with you guys on locals but even looking
at our Rumble comments in YouTube and
the emails I get our audience really is
all over the place we we get Evangelical
Christians we get hardcore Libertarians
we get we get soccer moms and we get you
know gay truckers like the audience
really is all over the place geography
ethically ethnically sexuality wise etc
etc and that is the Big Ten in terms of
voting I think that means you kind of
have to be a Republican and that's
really what I'm showing people that
there is a way that the Republican brand
which is banged up and you know it it's
it's toxic to a lot of young people but
there's a way to fix that I think that
is really well here's the best way to
answer it I think that really is through
the freedom message that is emanating
first out of Florida here so you could
look at it this way there's a there's a
freedom first version of all of this
from Florida the Texas version may be a
little bit more traditionally
conservative uh I'm in the place with
the one that I think is is the widest 10
and the place that we can grab the most
people and that's what I want to keep
pushing uh talway says Dave you commonly
say you don't have to be a republican
but you cannot be a Democrat with ones
like Blair Tulsi and so many others
bailing on the Democrat party but not
yet willing to commit to the Republican
Party is this the time we should be
looking at the creation of a strong
third party or should we focus on
ousting Biden company out of Washington
first look
uh I've discussed this many times to me
we just have to this is an extension of
the previous question you just have to
widen what the Republican party is we're
in a two-party system whether we like it
or not that isn't to say there can never
be a third party
Trump may start a freaking third party
if DeSantis gets the nomination Like
Anything Could Happen by the way Trump
gets a starts a third party well
congratulations now Democrats are in for
sure because you split the Republican
vote is what it is this is always a
debate right this is why a lot of uh you
know old-fashioned Republicans hate the
libertarian party because the
libertarian party it although it's done
particularly poorly in the last election
or two uh you know it would get you know
one or two percent and then the
elections would always be so close and
everyone would be like see it's those
damn Libertarians which I never
subscribe to because it's like no you
got to just do better uh it's not the
libertarian it's false for trying to
hold on to some principles but it is why
I I could not support the libertarian
candidate last time and I also uh I
obviously liked Trump and I wanted him
to win
um a third party right now I just don't
think it's going to work I think the
best thing that we can do is if you're
more on the libertarian side the
individual right side of this and stay
out of my life side of this and then
there's the you know let's say the more
religious conservatives over here figure
out a way to be like hey do we both
agree America is good yeah do you agree
and Live and Let Live yeah
um do we have some differences and well
I don't want to as the libertarian I
don't want to force you to marry anyone
you want and you're the religious person
as long as you don't force your views on
me we're going to be okay to live in the
same country that's a rich place to work
that's really where I want to keep
focusing
and maybe down the road that changes
into some third party thing but I think
that's the best way to get some
victories actually still at this point
uh Torrid says I was wondering what Don
Jr thinks about you supporting DeSantis
have you spoken with him has your
friendship remained the same since
you've changed your support from Trump
to the sand this well you know first off
on that as I've said many times
I still don't know if this is running it
obviously is looking like he is clearly
I think he is the best most competent
person to jump in on this so I make no
bones about that I'm not I'm not
pretending anything is that isn't or
isn't that is uh I like Junior a lot I
like Kimberly a lot Kimberly Guilfoyle
uh his wife
um you know we were together having
dinner the night that David and I met
Trump for the first time which you guys
have all heard that story
um I haven't spoke to Junior about it
specifically the last time I saw a
junior in person was some of you were
there for it was for the opening night
of the don't burn this country book tour
which we did in Palm Beach at The Improv
over there and he opened for me and the
room the room was electric I mean the
freaking roof almost blew off the place
uh We've traded a couple texts since
then you know I am going to do
everything I can to make sure that this
does not get personal or anything else
if Trump ends up the nominee and
DeSantis it remains my Governor at the
end that will be just fine with me I
would be thrilled at actually so
hopefully we can keep hashing it out in
an honest and fair way and if you didn't
see it I was actually on Kimberly
guilfoyle's uh show on Rumble a couple
days ago and she asked me about that
she's like Dave we're not really sure
where you're at you know what's going on
here and I laid it out as honestly as I
lay it out every day and I said I hope
that not everyone's going to go scorched
Earth on everybody I said I said
president Trump has a responsibility I
think to make the case for Trump and I
don't think these names and and the
nonsense around DeSantis is working so I
think if I I truly believe this and and
I said pollyanish earlier maybe this is
a bit Pollyanna of me but like I think
if I just tell you what I think and I do
it honestly
people people can get past some of the
political stuff and I have no doubt that
that Don Jr no I know this for sure not
no doubt that he lost many friends as
his dad got into politics right because
people people that knew him as a decent
guy or something like oh my God your
dad's Hitler so I don't think Don would
just be walking away from friends
because of you know a slight political
difference mad says is it true that the
real reason for Gen saki's hate for
Trump is that she is orange man's
long-lost daughter the new narrative for
the week she has become quite orange it
is always funny to me these people that
you see like the human version of them
and that's what you sort of got with her
you know she'd always be wearing a fancy
very expensive dress and a certain
degree of makeup when she was doing
those White House Press briefings but
then they put you on TV and they whack
you with powder and they get the all
this stuff on you and the redness and
the whatever and then they clearly you
know they either gave her an eye lift or
they do some kind of they suck your face
back or they inject you with something
else and everyone ends up looking like
one of these women on The View that look
like they're wearing masks of themselves
so is it possible because she has become
very orange since she is on MSNBC that
she's Donald Trump's long-lost daughter
wouldn't that just be the perfect ending
to all of this we just find out all of
these people are inbred and related and
it's time to pack it up and go home
everybody Buttercup says Prosecuting
Trump only serves to deliberately rile
up the Trump base possibly helping him
win the GOP Primary I believe it could
be possible that the Democrats are
actually yes afraid of running DeSantis
so if they can ensure a presidential
race against Trump they may be able to
repeat the 2020 upset I agree with this
and I have said for how many months now
DeSantis is the real threat he is
competent he is doing many of the Trump
or trump-like policies he is running a
state that is running like a perfectly
beautiful sound machine right now he's
taking the challenges on in the right
way he's fighting the media
appropriately he's not backing down to
the woke we now have this 20 State
Alliance fighting ESG like he's doing
all of the right stuff and has great
people around him they beat Trump
already they beat Trump already whether
you believe it was legit or not whether
Trump believes it was legit or not but
the question is can Trump bring let's
say you believe that what they told us
is true but Joe Biden got 81 million
votes and Donald Trump got 75 million we
basically know that's Trump's ceiling
where could possibly where could you
possibly get new Trump voters from but a
whole bunch of people may be tired of it
and they might drop out the other issue
with Trump is that because he is so
hated a certain amount of people just
vote because they hate him so now you
get more people voting against him and
probably less people voting for him
DeSantis clearly can get people to
change sides right we know we know it
because he won by 20 points this year a
million and a half votes here in Florida
after his last victory was only about
thirty thousand votes less than one
percent and then he wins by 20 percent
so
and also you just have to look at the
migration people keep coming here no one
is leaving everyone's coming everyone's
leaving California no one's going to
California that that's the simplest
version of all of this uh so I do think
there is something to that I think
you're going to see this more and more
the mainstream media will slowly be
propping up Trump more because they'd
rather go against Trump and Trump is
also much better for clicks right Trump
is good for clicks and Views so they
would rather have Trump so they'll get
their cash on clicks and Views and then
at the same time they'll get a weaker
candidate
and a guy who will always talk to them
rather than DeSantis who won't talk to
them isn't as good for clicks and Views
and is actually the real threat because
he can get stuff done Amy says I'm so
excited you're coming to Green Bay I may
have just landed right now while I'm
saying this it's incredible what's going
on here with time shift uh which is your
hometown uh I would like to know what
size onesie or t-shirt your two boys are
wearing so I can gift them a Green Bay
Packer shirt well that's very sweet I
guess you're coming to my event tonight
at University of Wisconsin I will gladly
say hello to you I think we're doing a
there's a private event I think
beforehand and they just get me doing
stuff and I go up there try to give a
different speech each time the kids so
Justin is now seven months and Luke is
uh five months but they're wearing
bigger stuff but these guys are huge
they're going to be freaking linebackers
or NBA centers so they're really they're
already into like 9 to 12 month stuff
Justin for sure and Luke is on his way
and I
appreciate the kindness of strangers I
do just like Blanche Dubois uh Pratt
says since you have made many many
comments about Saki and cringe and joy
less and sunny and Whoopi have you ever
received comments back from them no and
you know it's kind of unfortunate Whoopi
and I actually had a had a personal
connection through her cousin of mine I
don't want to get into the specifics of
it but we had traded some messages years
ago this was right when she was I think
yeah right when she had got on The View
and she was very very different at the
time and joy joy and I used to live two
blocks away from each other on the upper
west side I used to see her and her
husband often we'd say hi we'd talk
about stand up uh they they'd pet my dog
like you know we were more like-minded
at the time but but certainly she wasn't
like this insane thing so watching some
of these people just go completely
bananas it's so weird and then you know
there's Anna Navarro who I keep telling
you guys I'm told I live just like a
couple blocks from and it's like I will
see her at some restaurant one day and I
will have to say something right not to
not to make a a scandal out of it not to
throw a freaking drink on her or
anything but just like say something I
will have to but I no I haven't heard
from any of those people
um but I've heard from other people that
there's another set of people none of
whom you've mentioned not view people
that don't like me that I talk about but
what are you gonna do I didn't get into
this make friends I I have friends my
best friend on in the on this planet is
my buddy John who I met literally the
first day at kindergarten 41 years ago
uh so I've got my friends already so
some of the character cast the
characters either that I talk about or
that you know that that are on the show
or whatever some of them may come and go
but you know Jordan Peterson and his
wife were here for dinner two nights ago
and and you know we've become you know
Incredibly Close and I've become
Incredibly Close with Dennis and some
other people
um but you know if you're gonna do this
thing and you're gonna try to do it like
somewhat honestly and you're going to
talk about people not everyone's gonna
love you it's okay it's okay ventosa who
says I know you get backlash for some of
your off the cuff comments and rants but
that's what makes you you the comedy in
it all if we can't laugh at this crappy
world oh wait I meant crazy same thing
right I say keep the random sometimes
inappropriate comments and rants coming
what say you Dave there's no other way I
can do it there really is no other way I
can do it every now and again I'll let
one slide or I'll drop it or I'll pause
or sometimes I really do think that I
feel this when I'm doing the show that
you guys know what I'm thinking I don't
always have to say absolutely everything
I can do a little bit with a look or a
glance or I can you know side talk with
one of my guys here in studio but every
now and again I have to drop the F-bomb
I have to say something kind of
ridiculous because otherwise you go
crazy like how can you cover cringe
curtain that's that courage is good not
just cringe Jean-Pierre current
Jean-Pierre like how can you cover her
every day and and not occasionally drop
an F-bomb or make an off-color remark or
any of this endless lunacy like you'd go
nuts or or you just come off as deeply
and authentic right so if you watch CNN
and they're covering the same exact
things that I'm covering but Anderson
Cooper has to sit there and pretend that
Joe Biden slurring his words and walking
off stage the wrong way and shaking
hands with the air and all those things
that none of those things happened or
that none of them are odd you end up
being a robot more than a person and I'm
more person than robot on that note if
you're at the University of Wisconsin I
look forward to seeing you tonight we
have no show tomorrow three day weekend
for the team although we are having a
birthday dinner what do you want for
dinner I will cook you whatever meat
what cut do you want you want meat what
cut
filet mignon it is filet mignon for
Connor and the fine team on his 31st
birthday you're catching up with me man
getting old getting old uh part two of
my interview with Nikki Haley is up on
YouTube and rumbleful things up over on
locals ad free we leave you uh we leave
you with a cold close of former vice
president Mike Pence and we will see
everybody on Monday us I know we all we
all got our doubts about the last
election
and I want to assure you
I share the concerns of millions of
Americans about voting irregularities
and I promise you come this Wednesday
we'll have our day in Congress foreign